hi I'm Erik Bosse and this year's
Halloween movie is a hit it's a perfect
scary movie to watch with your paranoid
grandma and one thing that it does
really well is restage the scares from
the John Carpenter in 1978 classic with
some interesting directing choices that
make the film's final act pay off so
effectively it's nice to take a break
from our typical Marvel nerdery to go
into scary movies so let's break down
Halloween's ending how it put an
interesting twist on the ending of the
original film how it was cleverly set up
by this movie's earlier scenes and how
it leaves the door open for future
sequels and thanks to epic games for
sponsoring this video click on the link
in the description to download fortnight
for free and spoiler warning of course
so now you only have yourself to blame
and here we go so after Michael Myers
escapes again and kills a bunch of
people on Halloween night again all the
action eventually returns to the home of
Laurie Strode Jamie Lee Curtis who
booby-trapped the place to protect her
and her family from Michael and here we
learned that surprisingly this is really
what Laurie wants the story takes place
40 years after Michaels original attack
on Laurie in the first movie and it's
implied that she has spent the four
decades since horribly traumatized by
the event and carefully setting a plan
and emotion to kill Michael Myers so
what was Laurie's plan did Laurie
actually orchestrate everything in this
movie well the story begins with two
investigated podcasters meeting with
Michael and his mental hospital showing
him his mask and it's this moment that
reawakens the evil inside him and when
the reporters meet with Laurie afterward
she knows from this moment that the
clock is ticking for Michael's
inevitable return she's like a good
thing I spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars turning my home into a murder
house we later learned that Michael's
escape was actually caused by his
psychiatrist dr. Sartain this doctor
presumably caused the bus transporting
mental patients to crash and allowed
Michael to break out now why did he do
this well he said that he wanted to
better understand Michael's evil by
seeing him in the wild the way dr.
Loomis did and he believed Michael Myers
and Laurie Strode defined each other
that night in the past so to fulfill
their natures they need to be exposed to
each other sure however there were some
rumors from people who saw earlier cuts
of this movie that in an early version
Laurie was actually the one who freed
Michael that could have been the origin
for her line in this movie I prayed this
would happen so I could kill him and
perhaps the origin of that scene of her
getting drunk in her truck watching the
leave the facility like maybe in that
old version she rammed the bus to free
Michael now throughout this movie we see
very clearly how well-prepared laurie is
she is basically Sarah Connor of rural
Illinois putting those Second Amendment
rights to good use and equipping or
compound with security cameras a panic
room and slamming gates to close out
bedrooms one might even say it reflects
the boardgame mousetrap which
interestingly was foreshadowed in one of
the very first scenes Laurie's daughter
Karen and her husband Ray are setting
out mousetraps one of those mousetraps
prematurely Springs on Ray perhaps
suggesting that he is not equipped to
fight this kind of fight foreshadowing
his death whereas we see Laurie and
Karen have spent their whole lives
preparing to catch the mouse so when
Michael arrives at Laurie's house we see
this large scale loaded mousetraps bring
an action perfectly gradually boxing
Michael in room by room and then I don't
know if he caught this the bedroom where
she and Michael fight one-on-one is an
exact replica of the bedroom in the
Doyle house in the original movie Laurie
has been reliving this trauma in her
mind for 40 years designing the room
layout to be exactly the same turns this
into a rematch giving her the upper hand
this culminates when Michael throws
Laurie out the window over the balcony
he looks down and sees her motionless on
the ground but when he turns back to
check she's gone John Carpenter's
classic Dean kicks in obviously this is
a direct nod to the iconic ending the
first movie where the roles were
reversed and dr. Loomis looks down to
find Michaels body vanished essentially
Laurie has become Michael Myers as he
tries to attack her daughter and her
granddaughter she now creeps up on him
from the shadows
she says happy Halloween Michael and she
stabs him meanwhile Karen lers Michael
down into the panic room by pretending
to be scared because Laurie taught her
that posing as a helpless scream queen
is the perfect bait and they trap
Michael down there like a rat in a cage
and they burn in which I guess is what
you do if you really hate rats
now the final shots of the movie
explicitly never show Michaels body so
will Michael Myers return here's the
thing about Halloween John Carpenter
never really wanted these movies to
become endless derivatives and at
Halloween
- which Carpenter only wrote and
produced he'd interacted the movie ends
by killing off Michael in a similar way
with Loomis torching him now of course
history has taken its course with the
series ignoring Michael's death
and giving us 11 Halloween movies but
this one produced by the way by the guys
behind the eastbound and down was meant
as a restoration of sorts they worked
very closely with carpenter and God is
blessing on everything he even worked on
the movie with his son to compose a new
version of the movies theme and these
producers original plan was to actually
shoot two movies back to back but they
wanted to wait to see whether this first
movie was a success before they launched
into another one
so despite John Carpenter probably not
wanting this series to continue on and
on and on the fact that we do not see
Michaels body and this movie was a huge
success it probably means Michael Myers
will likely return for another Halloween
movie and if you need further proof we
may have gotten it if you were patient
enough to stick around through the end
of the credits you did do that didn't
you you should know to do that for every
movie at the very end of the credits you
listen closely you can hear the sound of
Michael Myers still breathing through
his mask now I could just be vent is a
spooky scare to follow you home or a
tease that he is still alive because
this is a force of nature that you can
never really kill my theory is that
because they wanted to shoot these
movies back to back and this first one
was such an homage to the original 1978
film I think the next movie will do
something similar to Halloween - and
continue the same night with a very
burned Michael Myers tracking out Laurie
Karen and Alison because these evil
incarnate a killing machine that feels
nothing and he will stop at nothing
until he kills the entire Strode
bloodline so my question for you is
should the next Halloween movie feature
a fight between Michael Myers and
Laurie's whole family or just Laurie
versus Michael comment down below with
your thoughts and thank you to fortnight
and at the games for sponsoring this
video I'm obsessed with fortnight and I
assume you or someone you know must be
as well basically the way it works is a
hundred players drop out of the battle
bus and they skydive onto the island
there you can collect materials and
weapons and the last one standing wins
you can check it out for free by
clicking on a link in the description
below the environment is completely
destructible and you can build using
materials you gather you can play in
solos or with your friends and duo's and
squads and again this is all free to
play on PC Mac ps4 Xbox one switch iOS
and Android season 6 is here in Port
Knight is constantly adding new
characters and content to the game over
100 unique cosmetics can be found in the
season 6 battle paths like the brand new
pets so yeah jump in yourself using my
link in the description below and click
on that link to download fortnight for
free and don't forget to follow me on
Twitter and Instagram @ e a vas for more
of these charming hunt takes and
subscribe to new rockstars for more deep
dives into the movies and the TV that
you love marble and Star Wars game of
Thrones we do all of it and yeah
including horror movies because I just
love being scared these pants are so
what I'm sorry it's just pointless to
change them they're gonna get wet again
[Music]